going to be adding 2009 Honda FIT
key Fit
2009 inside the key
there transition
on
add one key insert program key and turn
it
on okay I'll inser it back
[Music]
again tension
off
tension
off within second insert new key turn it
on new
[Music]
key turn it
on turn it
off turn it
[Music]
on
so I don't see any key light emo lights
out so I click
okay turn it
off
on success
okay this the key stop the
[Music]
car now the remote should programming
automatically let's see if the remote
works excuse
me
okay
lock
sweet I don't know panic I don't want to
hit panic but anyway everything's good
can you try that will open
too try the other
door yeah perfectly the old G you think
it's just